嘿大家好,今天我们要来聊一个
我跟你保证可能会彻底颠覆你过去所有交易认知的观念
我们常常听到大家在追求所谓的高胜率,对吧
但如果我告诉你,这个大家疯狂追求的东西
很可能就是让你一直在市场上赔钱的元凶
准备好了吗?我们马上开始
好,我先问你一个问题哦
你是不是也觉得去买那些高股息的股票或ETF感觉很稳
每年稳稳的领个5%股息好像跟定存一样安全
但你有没有想过
这个你以为超安全的策略很有可能
就是一个让你不知不觉陷入亏损循环的陷阱
好 我们就直接切入主题
先来猜解这个最普遍也最多人相信的迷思
高股息陷阱
你看这张图
真的完美呈现了我们脑中的美好小剧场
跟血淋淋的现实
左边是我们的梦想对不对
哇太棒了
每年稳赚5%股息
但右边这个才是残酷的真相
为了那区区5%可能会拿到的股息
你的本金其实是暴露在下跌15%
甚至20%的巨大风险底下
那这个陷阱最可怕的地方在哪
其实是在心理学
你是不是会这样安慰自己
没关系啦
就算股价跌了
就是所谓的贴席嘛
反正股息已经进我口袋了
有拿到钱就是赢
就是这种感觉
这种我有收到钱的错觉
让你以为自己的胜率很高
但实际上
你正在玩一个赢的时候赚一块
但输的时候
可能会赔掉三块甚至更多的游戏
这赚赔比真的太差了
好那问题来了
如果散户是这样想那专业的交易者是怎么思考的呢接下来我们要介绍一个全新的交易心态这个观念将会彻底改变你的游戏规则
核心概念就是这四个字叫做非对称优势
听起来好像很专业哼
其实讲白了意思很简单
就是我们设计的每一笔交易
如果做对了可以赚很多很多
但万一不幸做错了
只会赔一点点
我们要让获利跟亏损这两件事
形成一个强烈的不对等
我真的超爱这句话
他完全点出了重点
这不是说你去学一个什么
新的技术指标那么简单
不是的
这是一种从根本上
把你对交易的整个思考框压
全部打掉重练
好理论讲完了
我们来看点实际的
我们来一场对决
比较一下在完全相同的情况下
散户和专业人士的做法
他们的结果会有多么天差地远
这就是专业人士的剧本
你注意看哦
第一步
他们会先试探
他们绝对不会一次就把所有钱都压下去
不会
他们只会用一小部分的资金
比如说5%去测试一下水温
第二步
马上停损
只要发现
这档股票走势不如预期
他们会毫不犹豫的砍掉
这时候的损失
小到几乎可以忽略不及
但关键是第三步
加码
只要有一笔交易被他们看对了
开始赚钱了
他们会非常果断的
把资金压住在这个赢家身上
所以你看
到了最后一步
当我们这些散户还在后面追高的时候
人家早就已经准备要优雅的获利了结了
你可能会觉得
哎这听起来很厉害
但真的有这么神吗
真的可行吗
跟你说答案其实就藏在数学里我们直接来看数字数字是不会骗人的在看计算朱前我们要先搞清楚两个主角
左边是大家最爱的胜率
也就是你猜对的频率有多高
右边是赚赔比
意思是你猜对的时候可以赚多少
跟你猜错的时候会赔多少
很多人一辈子都在追求左边这个东西
但你马上就会看到
真正决定你长期下来
是赚钱还是赔钱的
其实是右边这个数字
好各位
这张图就是今天所有内容的精华
你一定要看懂
操略A是散户
你看他的胜率
哇高达80%耶
超神的对不对
可是你看哦
他赢一次只赚2万
但只到说一次就赔掉10万
再来我们看策略B
专业人士
他的胜率不到一半
只有40%
看起来超训的
但是他赢一次可以赚15万
输的时候只赔2万
那最下面这个期望报酬是什么呢
他就是你平均每出手一次
预期会赚到或赔掉的钱
你看策略A
虽然赢了8次
感觉很爽哦
但那两次大赔
一次就把所有获利都吃光了
所以长期下来
平均是亏钱的
反观策略B
虽然他输了六次
一直在停损
但那四次巨大的获利
完全可以盖掉所有的小亏损
长期下来
他的账户是稳定成长的
所以散户策略的最终期望值是多少
负的0.4
这数字告诉我们一个很残酷的事实
就算你有八成的时间都是对的
你瞎忙了半天
结果却是越做越亏钱
那专业策略呢
哇是正的4.8你想想看他有超过一半的时间都在承认自己看错都在小额停损但是长期下来
他的资产却是爆炸性的成长
这就是赚赔比惊人的威力
所以讲到这里
我们真的要问自己
一个很根本的问题了
在交易这件事上
你到底想当一个预测家
还是一个管理者
来 我们扪心自问
第一个灵魂拷问
当一笔单子进场之后
走势跟你想的不一样
你能不能放下你的自尊心
承认 好 我看错了
然后在亏损还很小的时候
果断地把它砍掉
好 再来
是第二个灵魂拷问
这个可能更难哦
当你运气好
一笔交易赚钱了
而且开始喷出
你敢不敢克服那种
啊 好想赶快卖掉落袋为安的恐惧
在已经赚钱的部位上
勇敢地加码
让获利去喷跑
所以你看
这就是今天最重要的结论了
一个成功的交易者
他的工作重点
从来就不是去猜未来会涨还是会跌
他不是神他预测不了未来
他的工作是成为一个风险管理者
把亏损控制在最小的范围
然后让获利被放大到极致
所以从今天开始
帮自己换个职称吧
你不要再当那个
每天心惊胆跳
焦虑不安的预测家
整天烦恼自己到底准不准
你的新身份是一个冷静的管理者
你只需要问一个问题
这笔交易的赚赔比好不好
这是不是一个值得我下注的好牌局
当你开始用几个角度去思考的时候
你会发现
整个交易的世界在你眼中会变得完全不一样